our next talk we'll be talking about
sketching for proving generalization
of right so yeah thanks a lot to the
organizers for inviting me so I guess in
this one maybe in contrast to the other
I guess learning machine learning
related applications of sketching this
one is actually not using sketching for
Designing new algorithms but instead
actually just for purely theoretical
analysis of support vctor machines so
I'll try to get back to it and I think
the talk is going to start out slow just
motivate support Victor machines and for
those not and then in the latter half I
guess it'll be more
technical so I guess speaking of support
V machines here we're talking about our
classification problems to keep as
simple as binary
classification and uh so maybe imagine
that you have a smartwatch and you want
to predict whether the wearer of the
Smartwatch is on a bike or in a car and
maybe you have some uh
measurements like the speed the person
is moving at and maybe the heart rate
and you have to figure out whether
you're driving or biking so maybe the
data could look something like this
right the blue dots are people on their
bikes some training data that you
collected and the triangles the red
triangles of people that are in their
car and maybe there's this thing you
know if your heart rate is high and your
speed is low maybe you're on a bike or
vice versa right if you're going very
fast and you have a low heart rate maybe
you're in a car or maybe you know this
is maybe an idealized setting I guess
you could have a very nervous driver
with a high heart rate and but anyhow I
guess this roughly looks this is what
you would expect right low heart rate
high speed tend to be people in car and
and vice versa so the idea here is given
this training data I guess we want to
train a classifier so that given a new
data point without its label we can make
a prediction as to what the label is
right so is this a square out here is
this a car or a bike right and I guess
just staring at the picture I guess we
would probably guess that this is
someone on a bike uh but maybe we can do
it a bit more
formally so for linear classifiers we're
going to train a linear model right so
just a hyper plane and everything on one
side we're going to classify red and
everything on the other side we're going
to classify blue so maybe this line here
could be a good model to train looking
at the training data right it definitely
perfectly separates the uh the red class
from the blue class and so maybe we can
use it to say everything below the hybo
plane is someone on the bike and
everything above is someone in their
car maybe a little bit more formally I
guess when we're doing this linear
classification linear classifiers guess
we'll describe our input elements as
feature vectors just a vector of D
numbers and the labels will be minus one
and one in this case most standard setup
and then the parameters describing this
linear model is I guess there a normal
Vector having coefficients W1 to WD and
then a bias B and the way once you have
such a set of parameters the way you
make predictions on a new point is just
you compute I guess the inner product
between your normal vector and your
feature Vector X and you add the bias
and you take the sign of this so I guess
it looks something like this this W is
describing the normal Vector of the hypo
plane and the bias is basically
describing the offset from the origin of
this
hyp and so of course the question is
once I have such a data set how do I
find this nice hypop plane in this
picture and there are several different
algorithms for doing it I guess the
simplest one is this perceptron learning
algorithm there a classic one uh so this
percepton learning algorithm is given
this data set how can I find the bias
and this normal Vector of a of a good
hyp
plane and here I guess we mean that the
hypop plane or model is it's good if it
classifies most of the training data
correctly or all of the training data
correctly and then I guess the general
idea is that if we have good performance
on the training data hopefully we have
good performance on on new data as well
right when need to make new predictions
I'll come back to this in the last half
of the talk doing it a little bit more
formally so this perception learning
algorithm I guess it's the simplest
algorithm you could almost come up with
so the algorithm is I guess you
initialize the parameters to let's say
zero or randomly and you do while
there's a data point in your training
data set uh
whose label is currently being
mispredicted by the hypop plane right so
you look at what prediction would I make
and if this is different from the actual
label I found a wrongly classified point
and then I update my model by saying the
new W becomes W + y * X and the bias is
B+ y right so the intuition for this
step is that you're going to make your
model more correct on this misclassified
data point in some sense right so maybe
and then when you're done when there are
no more points that are misclassified
you return this uh model that you found
right so in a picture I guess if you're
in some iteration maybe your bias is
currently zero you have this Vector W
here you look for a point that's
misclassified in this case uh this point
up here is misclassified so what you do
is I guess you you change your W by you
take the Vector X here you multiply it
with the label in this case the label is
minus one so you subtract off this
Vector X from from your W get a new
W and guess you also change the bias by
I guess adding the label of minus one to
the bias and so I guess the new model
you have is this one here right so you
kind of you change your hyper plane a
little bit and you shift it based on on
this misclassified point of course as
you can see right now it's correct on
this point but it became wrong on
another point
so so actually you can introduce new
Mistakes by by running this algorithm
and it's not even clear that it gets
better with every iteration when you're
running this perceptron and so it can
become wrong on new points uh so I guess
you can ask is it even a good algorithm
we'll even find a good hyp plane and
this is not obvious but you can you can
prove that if the data is linearly
separable Right meaning that is a hypop
that perfectly separates the data then
eventually if you run it long enough
you're G to you're going to find a
separating hypo plane this this is not
trivial to prove
so linearly separable I guess just mean
that it's possible to draw this
hyperplane that nicely separates the two
classes so this is linearly
separable now of course if I if I have
some training data that looks like this
and you run this Perron learning Al you
just get some separating hypop plane at
least in the vanilla version of
perceptron so of course you can ask
yourself right are all hypo planes
equally good at making new predictions
right so in this case this is a
separating hypo plane and and if you use
this one to make new predictions I guess
this point will be predicted as blue
because it's below the Hy plane and that
one down there will be predicted as red
and this at least when we stare at this
might not be the right way to make these
predictions and probably this hypo plane
here this looks better at at making
predictions just at least staring at it
so of course you can ask yourself you
know what is it uh that makes us prefer
this second hybro plane to the first
one and I guess the intuition is that
this second hop plane there's a large
gap or margin around it where there are
no data points in right so there's
really a big gap here out to the nearest
uh training points so this is guess a
large margin separating
hyperplane and I guess this is the
intuition behind support Vector machines
in support Vector machines you train a
model that is basically the largest
margin separating hyperplane that's the
one you you aim at finding at least in
the simplest version of support ex
that's the only one we'll we'll look at
here so in this talk I guess we'll
assume that it's linearly separable and
we'll always just look for the largest
margin separating hyper plane to the
nearest so so I guess we need to Define
what are these margins
formally and I guess if you just have
your W and your B then you can look at
this prediction that you're going to
make before taking a sign if you compute
the inner product in W and X plus a b
it's really a sign distance to the hyper
plane that you get out right it's
basically how far is uh is X from the
hyper plane up to a scaling of w and B I
can always represent the same hyper
plane by scaling W and B up by and down
by the same
factor uh so because of this scaling
we're going to assume that this normal
Vector has unit Norm right from here on
so w always has unit
Norm um then the margin on a training
point x i comma Yi is just you look at
whatever you would predict the sign
distance from the hyper plane you
multiply it with the label Yi and this
value is what we call your margin so I
guess it's a sign it's still a sign
distance but multiplied with the with
the
label and so you can notice that I guess
if you're if this is a positive margin
it means that your point is basically
classified correctly right if I if I
return the sign of this it must be the
same as the the label right if this is a
positive
number and likewise if it's negative it
means that you'll wrongly classify the
point and the larger the number is the
further away uh from the hyro plane the
data point
is so I guess in this case right
everything on on this side has a it's a
positive number before you multiply with
the label and everything up there has a
negative number before it multiply with
the label and so guess the red points
will have a positive margin and so will
the blue
ones and that is basically the simplest
version of support Vector machines is
just solving this optimization problem
maximize all the choice of WB and and
margin
gamma the uh I guess you have a
constraint that says all the margins
should be at least gamma and let's say
you insist on the norm of w being one
this is not a convex formulation I guess
the last constraint there is not so nice
but you there are ways of solving it
right then I'll not get into that that's
not the point of of this talk so but
that's basically what support Vector
machines are finding right the finding
the largest margin separating Hy in the
simplest
version I guess they super popular in
practice I guess probably all know right
I think the original paper has more than
50,000 citations it doesn't happen for a
theory paper and uh I guess the thing
we're trying to do here in this work is
can we try to give some theoretical
justification for why it helps to have
large margins in this model this linear
model that you're finding right so can
we prove that there's some benefits to
having large
margins I just want to say we're not the
first one I guess I'll come back to who
the co-authors are we're not the first
one to do this uh this has been done a
long time ago I think maybe Peter
Bartlet was one of the first to to
initiate this kind of study and but we
improved on some of their
BS so to study theoretic I guess we'll
have to make some assumptions on if you
want to prove that this has a good
performance we need to assume something
about how the data is obtained and how
what does new data look like I guess the
standard way to look at is in this pack
learning framework where I guess the
training data is assumed to be in IID
samples from some unknown data
distribution we don't assume anything
about the data distribution but only
that we get these IID samples from it
it's teching to prove something we will
assume that the Norms of all the data
points are bounded by one I guess you
could always scale things up but that
will affect the the bounce and it's
supposed to because I guess the margin
here if I scale all the points by aor
thousand the margin of the same Hy plane
also scales by effector thousand so it
should depend on somehow on the
magnitude of the of the Norms of these
vectors and the assumption is that the
new data is going to be similar to the
training data in the sense that a new
data point is sampled from the same
distribution d right so it comes from
this distribution D and we want to
understand what is the that this Hyo
plane that we train on the training data
correctly classifies this new data
point so that's what we want to say
prove that the performance of the
Learned hyp plane is good on on new data
at least if we if we manage to find a
hyp plane with large margins we want to
say that this means that it's also going
to perform well on new data and formally
we're going to measure it by saying
we're going to look at the error under
the distribution D of this set of
parameters W and B which is just the
probability overdrawing a fresh sample
from this distribution D of getting the
label wrong so what is if we're making a
prediction right we we're Computing this
W in product X plus b we're taking the
sign of it and this will be our
prediction of its label and if this
multiplied the true label is less than
equal to zero we would have made a
mistake right and if it's greater than
zero we would have correctly classified
it so we're just looking at what is the
chance of mispredicting uh the label and
we want to argue this is this is small
if you have good margins
and just yeah just to make clear right
that when you make new predictions we
only see X right we can make predictions
without knowing why right we just need
to take the sign of of this
part and and as I mentioned right
there's a lot of things already known
about this uh so let me show you like
this original work by bed and sha Taylor
from
99 so let's spend a little bit of time
on this one so so basically saying okay
so if I get niid samples training data
set uh from know distribution D where
you promised that all the Norms of these
vectors are at most
one then with high probability so with
probability one minus Delta over the
training data set right so the random
thing is the training data set here um
it says it holds for all
hyperplanes that have a margin of at
least scamma on all the training points
right so not just the one output by
support V machines but it says that any
hop plane that has a large margin to all
the training
points has a small error under this
distribution d
right so basically there there two terms
here there's one that depends on the
Delta log one over Delta over n and
there's another one a log Square n over
gamma squar
n okay and I guess this one minus Delta
has to be there right you could maybe
you could imagine an example if you
super unlocky maybe just get copies of
the same training point right if it's in
IID samples you can somehow be unlocky
and get an unfavorable data set so there
has to be some dependency on a Delta
there has to be some chance fails yeah
so is is this also somehow saying that
if you notice that the margin is big on
the sample then the margin will stay big
like I guess you could say yeah that's
almost what it's saying I guess it's not
so for the proof it's actually not
saying that the margin will stay big you
you'll actually see that this gap of
gamma is interesting but you'll say that
the margin remains non zero or non
negative sorry it will remain on the
right side so somehow this this margin
comes into play in proving this
generalization it doesn't stay gamma but
it stays greater than zero in some sense
that's the idea
so I guess the bound is saying right
large margins help right because the
larger this this gamma is the less data
you need uh to make accurate predictions
so so this I guess it's a theoretical
justification why it makes sense to to
look at the
margins there's also another previous
work uh with a different
tradeoff also show the same statement
but a log Factor Improvement in the
first term but a get significantly worse
dependency on the this
Delta why is it worse I guess it's the
same reason in as in Josh talk that
taking square root of a number that is
less than one makes it bigger right so
so this is a worse
dependency yeah also log in there right
so these are kind of like these were the
state-of-the-art before before our work
you can prove that this dependency on
Delta is optimal right you need a log on
or Delta overend term it has to be there
I guess that's almost always the case in
any of these pack learning things that
there's a dependency looks like this
yeah and are are there results that are
more relative to like the co variance of
the
distribution uh I suppos this I have to
say I'm not familiar with with working
that direction but presumably there's
something I guess this is also making
some assumption at least that this
distribution will give you data that is
separable otherwise it doesn't say
anything like it's an empty statement if
there's not a large margin separating Hy
so in that sense I guess it does say the
data distribution is easy if this is
possible
okay uh so I guess so this is the the
main result that I'm going to talk about
I think the reason why it's interesting
is maybe not so much for the result but
it's using sketching to prove it and
that's why I thought it would make sense
for for this work so this is from I
guess it's three years old by now uh so
so the result
is there an improve bound on uh what
generalization error you get if you
train a large Marchin separating hypo
plane now maybe you don't remember from
the previous side so it's a log Factor
better in the first term has the optimal
dependency on on Delta here and I guess
there was also this alternative bound
that that match this one in the in the
first term here but had a much worse
dependency on on Delta so so it's an
improvement or I guess the best of both
in some
sense um you can also ask is this the
right dependency on the margin gamma we
already know the dependency on Delta is
optimal is it the right dependency on on
gamma right should it look like log n
over gamma squ n
and in this work we also show a lower
bound proving that yes this is the right
dependency you can come up with the data
distribution so that with constant
probability over this if I get in
training samples there is a hyper plane
that has large margins on all the data
but also has a large error under this
data
distribution so so it's basically
complimenting it as long as your upper
bound is saying for all hyperplanes with
large margin you have small error it's
tight there's nothing more you can do so
it's like the right answer to it
so so I guess this is the the theorem
statement that we'll try to to prove and
I'll try to go
slow guess this is from from here on it
gets a little bit more
technical this is what we like to prove
we like to prove that if I have with
good probability over training data set
every single large margin hyper plane I
will have small error under this data
distribution
D and the proof is where we're using
sketching so I try to maybe do a first
kind of motivation for why is sketching
interesting and where does it come into
play and then I'll try to give details
that are a little bit more
messy so so I guess the starting point
is okay let's say instead of having I
guess the infinitely many hypop planes
that have a large margin there could be
an infinitely many infinitely many of
them right so what if there was some set
H that contained all the large margin
separating hypo planes and this set is
small it's some discrete set of
hyperplanes and moreover it doesn't
depend on the concrete training data set
but let's say just as imagine there's
some set of Hy planes so that no matter
what end training points I get I'm
guaranteed that if I had a hyper plane
with large margins it would be an AG so
of course this is not true right but
let's just pretend that this is true
we'll see how can we use this assumption
right so somehow there's a set H that
contains all this large margin
separating hyp
then you'll take then there's a fairly
simple way of proving uh generalization
and that would be basic you want to show
using just a union bound and standard
concentration inequalities right that uh
it's very unlikely when I get a new
training data set that there is a
hyperplane in ag that has large margin
while it also has a large chance of
making a mistake so make S I want to
show this is super unlikely that you can
find something in the in age that has
large margins but also has large
uh chance
inut because if I can rule this out then
basic I get the first thing up there if
I can find some large margins it will
have a small error because everything
with large margin has small error so so
and this is this proving this is is very
simple right so you can start with okay
so I have this discrete age just look at
one of them look at one hypo plane in in
ag and let's assume that this is a hypo
plane that actually has a large chance
of mispredicting a new point
so same and importantly right having a
large chance of mispredicting a point
doesn't depend on the concrete training
data set right it's just some it only
depends the distribution d right so it
doesn't depend on what data set do I get
for training so I have let's say I just
have look at one Hy plane this one here
and there's a big chance when I get a a
new data point that it makes a
mistake
so B what I want to argue is then it's
super unlikely that all the margins are
large on the training data
why does that make sense right
well whenever I get a new Point there's
a big chance it makes a mistake right so
that means that the margin is even less
than zero right when I make a mistake
the margin is
negative and the train data niid samples
from this distribution d right so it' be
very unlikely that I don't see a point
where I make a
mistake basically right every single
time I get a training point the
probability that I don't make a mistake
is at most one minus the error or it is
exactly one minus the error
make
sense so this is even the chance of uh
only seeing positive margins not just
margins of gamma but just seeing
positive
margins so the chance I only see
positive margins if I off an error is
very
small you just yeah approximate this by
e to the minus the error times n and you
get
something
so just by
sitting if I have an error that's at
least log the size of H over Delta
divided by n the chance that this single
hyber plane um makes no mistakes on any
of the training data is at most Delta
over the size of H right and now I can
just Union bound over all of the
hypotheses in all the hypop planes in
this discrete set right and say there's
only size of H of them so with
probability one minus Delta over
training data set there will not even be
a single hypo plane in ag that that at
the same that both have a large error
and all the margins are are large right
make sense they just say it's super
unlikely that you would you would see
any single hypop plane that has all
margins non- negative while also having
a large chance of making mistake so it's
just a completely standard concentration
and uh Union
bound maybe worth noting here it could
be the case that there are no such H Hyo
planes in the in ag that have all
margins large the theorem statement
doesn't say anything like that it just
says it's unlikely that there's
something that has large margins while
also having large
error doesn't promise US that there's
one that has large margins and small
error but the the if I manage to find
one on my training data set I guess
there is one right so if I manage to
train a find a good hyp plane it will
have that has large margins then I know
that this error is going to be
small
so this is basically what you get where
is the number of samples again yes
that's the end the number of training
points so I guess this goes into the
exponent here because you have niid
samples every single time you will see I
guess you'll see a witness to yeah this
one I'm making a
mistake okay so I guess in some sense
you can say it's highly likely that the
training data set is very representative
for this
uh for this hypoth this set age of of
hypop planes right every single hypop
plane in this age um if it if basically
if all the margins are large it must
also have a small chance of
mispredicting otherwise you would have
seen it
here so what we'll try to do now to try
and generalize this because we don't
just have a discrete set of hypop planes
right we have an infinite number of them
um the main idea is in some sense to use
sketching to map all the large margin
hypo planes to a small discrete set of
hyperplanes that's not too large this
kind of makes sense right that's what we
do in sketching right we guess we take
some large object or large collection of
them and map them to to fewer ones so
that's what we'll try to do we'll try to
use sketching to map large margin Hy
planes to some discret set H that's not
too big and it will have size
exponential in one over the margin
squared log n and then if we just plug
that in in place of H up here we get the
generalization bound we're looking for
unfortunately it's not that simple
because we can't just sketch it and and
do the union bound as we did here we
need to be a little bit more more
careful that's the main kind of
intuition in the proof that if we can do
this sketch basically there not that
many different hyperplanes to worry
about only the one for every possible I
guess bit string or compressed version
of a hypop plane and then all of those
will be well represented by the training
data set that's kind
of so so that's so what is the sketch in
this case so we're going to allow a
randomized sketch so if I have a hyper
plane we would like to have a some kind
of sketching mechanism that takes this
hypop plane and turns it into a bit
string so guess a simp you just produce
a bit string of K bits and then we would
like it to be the
case um if I have a point x then I
should be able
to approximate this inner product with w
and X plus the bias B and I want to be
able to just from my sketch of w andb
there should be some function it doesn't
have to be in a prod doesn't have to be
just a function a way of computing an
approximation to this uh basically to
the the sign uh the margin before
multiplying with Y Mak so it's just a
sketch it basically preserves these
inner products or allows us to recover
the inner products between W and and X
that's basically what we're interested
in uh I guess for proven generalization
it would have been nicer if it was not a
randomized sketch but then it's harder
to design a sketch so I guess there's a
trade-off here and we would like it to
be easy to design this sketch right so
so the reason why we allow randomized
sketches to make it easier to give a
good
sketch um and I guess for the sake of
the proof this decoding function I guess
this F is allowed to depend on like you
can see the random choices that are
being made by the sketch if you have
some random string that is used to
sketch you can look at that during uh if
when you want to estimate this W's inner
product with X plus
b actually there should not be an
absolute value here that's a mistake on
the slides forget that absolute value on
the SL have to approximate
it so so of course it's randomized and
we will allow it to fail and we will say
that for any fixed WB and X I guess I'm
still assuming everything has both of w
and X has unit Norm uh I'm allowed to
fail with probability 1/ n^ s so there's
some small failure probability right
that I do not manage to preserve uh
approximate W transpose X
Plus and what we're aiming for is K
being log in over gamma
Square I think this sketch I'll get back
to what it is it's basically just jail
plus a randomized rounding I think you
can almost guess it if you know this
kind of work so the sketching part is
not so it's just
jail um so but basically the main idea
is in some s we'll take all these
different hyp planes and then we'll kind
of sketch them into one of these few bit
strings and in some sense this will be
our these bit strings will be our
discrete set of hypotheses that
[Applause]
we're so so the tricky part now I guess
if we want to come up with like before
when when we assumed there was only
discrete set of hyperplanes we have to
look at what we looked at is really or
we would like that this training data
set is a good representation of for
every hyperplane in this set AG um the
number of classified points on the
training data set are the ones with
small margins should be a good
approximation of its error under the
distribution
D we like to come up with some similar
definition uh
here so let's say we have a sketch right
so a k- bit sketch a way of taking uh of
sketching these uh W's and
B's and let's start by looking zooming
in like before we our proof was
basically look at one hyper plane and
show that it's extremely unlikely that
you don't see any mistakes in the
training data if it has a large chance
of Mak mistake so we're going to do
something similar here so first we're
going to try and let's start by fixing
the sketching like all the random
choices of the sketch and also the
output of the sketch right so look at
some output C so just a bit string and
also fix the randomness of the
sketch then I'd like to show somehow
something similar to before we would
like to argue that something the
performance of this sketch C the one we
fixed here on the on the training data
is very close to its error under this
distribution
D let try here so we going to do
something similar to before we're gonna
say Okay assume that there's a big
chance that you see a point if I'm using
this sketch C and I'm
approximating uh this x transpose b x
transpose X transpose W plus b I'm
including the
label I'm looking at this I guess this
is an approxim of what the margin is
right this is so this is what my sketch
would approximate that the margin is
let's say that there's there's a big
chance that I'll approximate the margin
to be something less than gamma
half then I'd like to argue then oh then
it should be then I I'll basically see
an example in my training data set I
will see one training point where this
approximated margin is less than gamma
half this is basically the same as
before before we said assume there's a
big chance of misclassifying a point
then I'll also see it in the training
data here I'm just saying assume there's
a big chance of approximating the margin
to something small then I'll also see it
in the training
data that make
sense okay and and this is exactly the
same proof as before right I say well
this is it's very if it's very likely
that I approximated to something small
the train points are IID so I just get
in copies of it and the chance that I
don't see it in my training data is is
super small
you always see um an example of a point
whose margin is approximated to
something
[Applause]
small we're going to do the same as
before we're just going to Union bound
over all the possible sketches this time
right because now I know it's a k bit
sketch so there's only two to the K
possible C's so that that's basically
how I discretize it right there's not
too many possible sketches I could have
produced so now I'm going to say for all
the possible
sketches um it's very unlikely that if
it had a large chance of
approximating a margin to something
small I'll also see it in the training
[Applause]
data so basically this is just a union
bound over all of them so basic what I
have now is I fixed the randomness of
the sketch and then I know with very
high probability over the training data
set um it holds that every single sketch
I could produce every output bit string
I could
produce um if it has if it approximates
all margins to something
large um then there's also there's only
a small chance over a new sample that uh
it will approximate its margin to
something small makes sense it's
basically just saying the training data
set will accurately I guess if you don't
if you approximate everything to
something big on the training data set
it's also very unlikely that a new point
will be approximated to something
small so just
uh I guess it's just kind of saying that
the train data set is somehow
representative of of all these all these
different sketches at the same
time uh and I guess I guess there's no
promise that there exist even a single C
that approximates everything to
something large but if there is those c
will also have a small chance of
approximating something to something
small
afterwards okay so in some sense we say
we could say that the training data is
representative for this fixing of the
randomness right if I fix the randomness
all the different sketches I could
produce are going to behave similarly on
the on the training data as they're
going to do on a new Fresh Point from
the
[Applause]
distribution okay I have to do one more
step I guess this the the difficult part
of the proof so I'd like to somehow come
up with a way of saying the training
data is nice without talking about the
random choice of the sketch and so the
problem with this thing is that it's I
have a
fixed Randomness in my sketch and then I
can say oh for this choice of Randomness
my um my training data set behaves
nicely but I like to come up with a
statement that doesn't depend on the
randomness of the sketch somehow just
say this is a nice data set this is a
typical data set and for this data set I
know all large margin all large margin
hyperplanes generalize well to new data
so I want to get rid of this fixing of
SNF that's the last step of of the
technical part here and that I'm just
going to use Markov I guess if the
failure probability is only Delta Over N
I can say something like
this probability one minus Delta over a
training data set all the stuff in this
blue box holds with probability one
minus one over n over the choice of the
randomness in the
sketch statement from before holes right
every single output in the sketch that
approximates everything to something
large also has a small error under this
distribution
make sense
so this is a property that only depends
on the training data set right I I'd
like to get rid of depending on the
sketch so I'm saying my training data is
representative if when I pick my random
sketch if I sketch all the training data
to something with large margins when I
try to approximate the margins it also
means that they have a small error under
the distribution D small chance of
getting of predicting small
margins so the important part is doesn't
depend
on so let me just wrap up here and see
this is enough a technical definition
I'm going to wrap up and then there's be
some discussion that's more interesting
so this is the just wrapping up the
proof uh so now we can look at let's say
I have a large margin separating Hye and
let's say the train data is
representative both hold at the same
time here I can look at what is the
error of this hypop plane under the
distribution
D just you write it as the expectation
of an indicator for making a mistake
right I'm just saying I misclassified
the margin is less than
zero then I am going to use the promise
of the
sketch sketch is saying well basically
if I have a point whose margin is less
than zero the chance that I estimate
this margin to be more than gamma over
or the chance I'm estimate to be less
than gamma over two is basically almost
all the time right I know my sketch
preserves all these uh margins I
estimate them accurately so it's only
with probability one over n squ that I
failed to uh to estimate it to within
this additive
gamma I pull this out as an additive 10
n squ
term you rearrange the order of
expectation and the
probability and and last trick is to
turn it into something that can use that
sketches
representative
so basically I split this expectation
into the those choices of sketches for
where for which there exist a training
Point that's estimated to have a small
margin and then I guess the other ones
where all of the training points are
estimated to have a large
margin the first case I can always uper
bound this term here with one so I just
get this term here
and in the other case I guess I can now
condition on all the margins being
estimated to something
large so and then we're done okay so
this is the last technical part the
first term here what is the chance that
exist a point whose margin is estimated
to something small it's just a sketch
the chance that you estimate to
something small when all the margins are
large is very small you can Union bound
over all end points and all of them will
have their margin uh roughly preserved
the other part is using that is
representative so
everything that has so my hyb plane has
all margins estimated to something large
it also means there's only a small
chance
and they estimate to something small
under the distribution
D so that's all for the technical proof
I just guess want to show you roughly
how the it went so let's wrap up um so
so basically what I'm saying if I have
this sketch that outputs to K bits then
I can proove generalization that just
gets a K in the generalization
bound that's the main idea if I have a
good sketch I get generalization
here so it's just saying with high
probability over the train data set is
going to be representative for this
concrete sketch and so all hybo planes
that have a large margin on the training
data will also have a small error on the
distribution and I guess this approach
of using sketching has been done before
also in in these boosting type alums
analyzing large margin voting
classifiers I guess that's where the
kind of outline comes
from what does the sketch do I guess
I'll just quickly skim over it the
sketch is very simple you just B is just
a number you can just write it down in
your sketch it doesn't take much many
bits to write down a very good
approximation of B you do a S John Lin
stra Matrix into log in over gamma
square
dimensions you project your W into these
few Dimensions you randomly round each
coordinate to an integer multiple of one
T then you get some uh vector and then
you just write down or whatever this
Vector is and if you're careful this
only takes of T bits you can prove that
this works I'm not going to do it here
but you can prove that this preserves
all these approximations to within gamma
half with with very good
probability so then the final way to
make these estimates is just well you're
allowed to depend on the randomness so
you you also do JL on on the X that
you're about to approximate the margin
for
you do the JL you multiply with the
rounded projected W and you add this
approximated bias so that's how the
sketching goes and this is basically
inspired by I guess a JL lowerbound by
Alon and cl as a followup of Janis in my
low Bound for JL so so maybe they use
this sketch to prove a low Bound for for
J that's a summary of of I guess the
result so get this generalization bound
maybe to the lighter things we also
mentioned we had this law bound that
says uh with constant probability there
exist a hyperplane with large margins
and a large error at the same time so
it's tight if this is the kind of
guarantee you
want in the work we also generalize it
to what happens if it's not all the
points that have a large margin but all
but a t fraction that have a margin less
than gamma you can do some you can also
prove generation here we did that
basically the same
approach um I think an interesting
question is well this is saying kind of
like all the possible Hy planes with
large margins generalized well and the
low bound is saying there exists one
that has a large error what if I run
support Vector machines maybe it's not
that one I find right I could find
something that's better that could be
the case right I'm not this is just
there exists someone with large margins
for a terrible performance what if it
what if I know my algorithm is support
Vector
machines very interestingly it's work by
hankin covich that show so what is it
saying is generalization bound says oh
if I only look at the one that's
produced by support Vector machines or
the perceptron learning Al any of those
two if the output happens to have large
margins then it actually generalizes
better than this guarantee up here right
so for those concrete algorithms you can
get even better generalization you can
prove uh you get rid of this log factor
in the first term maybe analyze but you
have to take the algorithm into account
and what it's
doing interestingly I talked to a just a
few days ago and he said oh there's a
bug in our svm proof right so so the
proof I guess they say they've been
trying to fix it for a while uh so but
the percepton is fine so at least for
the percepton learning Al this statement
is true for svm I guess technically it's
not completely clear whether or not this
terization
Falls then I guess you could ask okay
can I
prove a lower Bound for svm or
perceptron what if it's a Concrete
algorithm and then we also in this work
we also show well no matter what your
algorithm is um there's a data
distribution where the error of whatever
your algorithm produces is at least this
one over gamma Square in and under this
distribution there's also a good chance
that there exists a large margin hyro
plane so I guess this is
saying you can run any learning
algorithm maybe it doesn't maximize the
margins so I cannot so basically this is
saying no matter what your algorithm is
doing it's going to have a large error
but it is possible to find something
that has a large margin even if your
algorithm isn't doing it it's definitely
possible to find a large margin crating
Hyo
plane here I guess you could say right
you cannot put it into the algorithm
that your algorithm is always producing
a large Mar cing highy because not all
algorithms are doing so so the low bound
has to say something like any algorithm
has a terrible performance and it is
possible to produce something that has a
large margin that's basic what our
theorem statement
say so I guess that's what I wanted to
say um this main idea is to try can you
can use this sketching technique inside
a generalization proof that you can kind
of use it to discretize the number of
hypotheses you need to to consider um
without actually using it in your
algorithm that's name right from this
one
yeah perhaps I miss
something didn't you have the Assumption
I'm sorry perhaps I missed something but
is the Assumption throughout that you
are starting with data that is linearly
separable uh yes yeah that is the
Assumption here in our work we also have
what happens if uh all but a t fraction
of the data has a margin of gamma then
you get some different generalization
bound it depends on this but I think it
was already complicated enough so I
didn't want to throw that in as well but
but you can also prove something for
some data might you know outliers and
and stuff like this what happens then
the second part of that question is
isn't it almost as much work to figure
out if your input data is linearly
separable as it is in solving it it's
the
same uh you have input data you don't
know what it is
yeah okay if you if if your input data
okay so if I want to check whether the
input data is separable with a large
margin if if that's if that's the only
thing I want to check then you can
actually this perceptron can be made to
run very fast if you if I check if it
has a large margin I'm not exactly sure
whether there's hardness for tiny
margins you can do it in polinomial time
at least but exactly the run time I'm
I'm not
sure any other
questions sorry I want to ask a question
about your what you said toward the end
which you said
um like this lower bound just shows that
uh there is a bad there is a bad
separating hyper plane with large margin
but maybe that's not the one svm finds
but uh as you defined svm the definition
you gave I believe maybe I misremembered
svm wasn't an algorithm it was a problem
it was like so so when you say that do
you mean a particular implementation to
solve that optimization problem or do
you mean like the bad the bad hyper
plane might not be the max margin hyper
plane uh yeah okay so yeah for the low
bound it's
saying the hyber planes that have
margins gamma there might even be some
that have a slightly larger or slightly
smaller margin uh what can
like svm if you solve the optimization
problem exactly I guess you'll get some
output uh and it's for most cases it's
going to be unique so I guess that's
what I meant here and that's what they
claimed in this original paper that the
one that I get by solving this svm
optimization problem is going to
generalize well um right our lower bound
statement is I guess piing a very
particular one that has large
margins whether it could be the one
produced by svm it's not clear I guess
I'm not one could try to prove that svm
could actually produce the one that that
has a terrible performance I don't think
that's the case to be clear if that were
the case then it would it would mean
that the bug here is unfixable yes okay
yeah yeah
[Applause]
exactly
question one more
time
you